Now let me explain some of the reasons
why God will allow calamities and evils
and satanic onslaught. Let me take the
case of
Job. Not every satanic onslaught is
because God is punishing you by removing
his hand of protection from your life
because of your sin and rebellion. God
will allow the righteous to be afflicted
in order to vindicate them and exalt
them in the sight of heaven. Let me
explain what I mean by that. Are you
ready for me to go a little deeper?
Because I don't want to go too slow, but
I don't want to rush through this
because I'm here to serve
you. You want me to go a little bit
deeper? What do I mean by that? Okay. If
you ever paid attention to Job 1 and 2,
you're going to note that the inspired
author, many believe Moses wrote it.
Anyway, whoever did mentions three
groups who are before one another in
heaven. Notice in Job 1:6 and Job 2:1,
it says, "There was a day in which the
sons of God presented themselves to
Yahweh Jehovah."
That means the sons of God appeared to
before God in heaven where God appears
in visible glory in a visible shape in a
visible form visibly seated on a throne.
And I'll give you examples of that a
little later. But then it says, "And
Satan also was among them." So pay
attention. This is a heavenly
scene. This is a heavenly scene. Okay,
pay attention. Heavily seen. Tatiana
Aliyia Summer is asking how old I am.
Should I tell her? Anyway, heavily seen.
Focus with me,
guys. Notice it's not just God and
Satan. The sons of God are there as
well. The sons of God are there as well,
meaning angels. Now, another point to
remember.
The Lord tells Satan, "Where are you
coming from?" He goes to and fro the
earth. I've been traveling the entire
earth. Why? Number one, that tells you
Satan is not omniresent. He cannot be in
more than one place at the same time. He
can travel much faster than we can in a
nancond. He can be here and then he can
be in Europe. But he still has to travel
from place to place nonetheless because
he's not God. Satan as a creature is
still bound to time, space, and place.
Though he can travel much faster and I
would dare say even at the speed of
light, but he's traveling to and fro the
earth. Everyone got
that? So he's not
omniresent. Nor is he omnisient. Why is
he traveling to and fro the earth?
Because he's looking for a righteous
victim to devour. 1 Peter 5:es 8-9. You
want meat, right? So, I'm going to give
you meat. 1 Peter 5:es 8-9. As Holy
Spirit guides me to recall and interpret
scriptures for the glory of Jesus, so
you can fall in love with the depth and
beauty of the Bible, God's word. 1 Peter
5:8-9, "Be sober, be vigilant, because
your adversary, the devil, walks about
like a roaring lion." There you go.
Seeking whom he may devour. So, Satan
was traveling to and fro the earth to
look for a righteous servant of God to
devour, devour, and destroy his faith.
Resist him like Job did. steadfast in
the faith like Job, knowing that the
same sufferings are experienced by your
brotherhood in the
world. You c you catching it? So, Satan,
why are you traveling to and from the
earth? Because I'm looking for a victim,
someone close, near and dear to your
heart. Because I want to destroy the
faith of the faithful. Satan hates Satan
hates the church and he hates the
righteous whom God loves. And so the
entire purpose of his life is to cause
holy men and women to lose their faith
or to fall into sin and shame the
Lord. That's his purpose in
life. Why do you think then God exposes
his motive?
God says, "So you've considered my
servant Job,
huh?" You understand? God knows why
Satan is there. So learn that when Satan
finds a victim, he then goes before God
and then accuses him in order to get God
to allow him to test
him. Notice when he appears before God,
when he found what he considered to be a
victim. But until then, he was traveling
to look for someone to victimize, to
destroy. And so God knowing and seeing
what saints about to so go. So he says
to him, "Oh, so you considered my
servant Job, huh? Because you've seen
there's none like him on all the earth.
A righteous man who fears God. Yeah, my
eyes are on him, Lord. And I tell you
what, he doesn't fear you for nothing.
Job only loves and fears you because
look, look, you've given him 10
children, a beautiful wife, you've made
him rich and prosperous and blessed him
with good health. Of course, he's going
to love you cuz he loves you for the
blessing. He doesn't love you for
you. You get
it? Now, why didn't God just shut Satan
up and say, say, "Get behind me. Get
thee
hence leave my presence. Do you know
why? Now you're gonna see how deep and
beautiful the Bible
is. When Satan brought this accusation
against Job before God, who was
observing this
conversation, who was listening,
overhearing this conversation between
God and the
adversary?
Angels. So you understand? Let me now
show you how evil Satan is. You want to
understand how evil he
is? You want to You want to see how evil
he
is? This is why our Lord warned us, "Be
wise as
snakes, but harmless, innocent as
doves." meaning know how Satan thinks,
how he operates to protect yourself
against his schemes, but don't adopt his
tactics. Satan is now not only accusing
Job's motives before the angels. Now
remember, Satan was a spirit creature.
So like these angels, he's limited in
knowledge. And like these angels, he had
the potential to sin. Meaning these
angels also have the ability to deny
God, doubt God, and turn against
God. So now notice his mastermind. He's
now accusing Job's integrity and God's
assessment of Job because God says
before the angels, Job is righteous,
none like him in the earth who fears
God. So that's God's assessment. Satan
now calls God's assessment into question
in order to create doubt in the hearts
of the angels. Oh yeah. Are you sure
about that God? Look the reason why he
loves you and he holds his integrity.
You've made him rich. You've given him
perfect health, a beautiful family, a
beautiful wife. Of course he loves you.
So what he's doing here is saying China
trying to kill several birds with one
stone.
not only caused Job to lose faith like
Job's wife. See, he won with Job's wife
because in Job 29 and 10, when Job's
wife saw
Job's pitiful condition, she goes,
"Curse God and get it over with, man."
So, she lost faith. Satan won against
his wife, but he failed against
Job. Okay? So, not only does he want an
opportunity to destroy Job's faith and
make him turn against God and hate God
because he wants to damn all
believers to hell, which by the way
shows you can lose salvation. Because
these chapters destroy tulip of
Calvinism because if tulip is true, then
Job was already predestined to believe
and he'd be kept by the spirit from ever
falling away. So then what point was
there in even allowing this
test? It's meaningless. And God is
playing a game which would be
blasphemous. So the other thing that
Satan wants to do is get the
angels to start doubting God's judgment.
Wait, if God is wrong about Job, then
maybe God is wrong about Satan. And
maybe God is wrong about a lot of
things. So why should we trust him? God
doesn't know as much as we thought he
did. You see the
mastermind? So what do you think would
have happened if God simply told Satan,
"Get
lost." without ever vindicating Job and
proving Satan to be a liar.
What do you think this would have done
in the hearts of the angels who would
have observed that? Wow, God was really
quick to throw Satan out of his
presence. He must have hit a nerve. But
why did God get so angry if there wasn't
some truth to the accusation? And so,
Satan would have caused doubts to arise
in the hearts of the angels, thereby
causing them to rebel.
You see how deep Job 1 and 2 is and why
the story is so
rich. So what is God doing? Number one,
he's vindicating Job's honor before
heaven. Number two, he's exposing Satan
for being a wicked liar that you can
never trust. And number three, he's
protecting the angels from falling under
God's wrath due to Satan's sway and
deceit.
See what God is doing? He's he's going
to vindicate Job in the eyes of
heaven, showing the angels can trust
God's discernment, exposing Satan as a
liar who can never be trusted, and
protecting the angels from falling in
sin and then God's
condemnation,
right? You see how deep it is?
You see how deep it
is before I move
on. So this
answers provides one of the reasons
why God allows
satanic affliction or
calamities in order to vindicate his
righteous servants. in honor to honor
his servants and exalt them in the eyes
of heaven. Because when Job passed the
test, the angels truly saw firsthand Job
is a man of integrity, a man of holiness
who loves the Lord and Satan is the
liar.